[Music]
Hi, I'm Pablo Carlier, a partner at
Ginger in Google Cloud, and today we're going to see
how to start taking our first
steps with the vernet engine. At Google,
we've been working for years around the
new paradigm that is modernizing
all applications,
microservices, the  bobs and the new
technologies that are emerging
around these movements are
those that have allowed us to
reach billions of users every day
at google we know well the importance
of this type of technology in fact
we have been
working with them for more than 10 years  and every second
we are lifting more than 6,000
containers where does vernet really come from
to start working with it we have
to think about the origins of
this technology and these origins come
from more than 10 years ago inside our
house using something that  it is called borg
because it is based on the notion of a master
who is looking for computing resources in
all  the servers that are
controlling the users can
interact with it through a
command line a graphics card or some
apis and board will send to a component in
each of the nodes that controls the
precise instructions to be able to create
this workload we
use  In all our
board services as fundamental support, in fact,
our own virtual machines
run as work tasks, thus allowing
functionalities such as our live
migration, the importance of this
work model is that it is declarative, we
tell the infrastructure what
we expect from it instead of giving it
instructions
what is it then that vernet is that see notes
is the implementation of board in an open way
if you see architecture it is very simple and
very similar users interact with
a command line an api or a
graphical interface with this master who
will be giving instructions  to a people
who live in the nodes the led club to
express the n  needs that
each one of them has so we can manage
container clusters on multiple
servers we support most
clouds and most
infrastructure manufacturers and multiple
container formats and it is also opensource and
is breaking molds that
vernet shenjing is the proven service
and  reliable network cover is managed in
the cloud in the last 10 years we have
been working to bring this
technology closer to other users and to
industrialize its since the origin of the
notion of the container within
google more than 10 years ago until the appearance
of cuber  it's like an open source project in
2014 until the first version of the cuber
nets engine with general availability
in august 2015 we have been
reliably serving hundreds of
thousands of users around the world for years and the
latest versions are even starting to
allow us to deploy this same type  of
services in your facilities
thanks to the future that falls man cooper
minds  engine is therefore
a turnkey solution ready to work in
minutes not in weeks it
is a cover net it is reinforced managed
by our site the ability angers thousands
of engineers who are dedicated to
monitoring and operating the
workloads that run on google cloud to
give them maximum availability
has a 100% managed control plan
we take care of all
the operations related to the
master's degree and we also do not charge for it
so we can also achieve
zonal or regional redundancy and of
course we have native integration with
many fp services  network
balancing continuous integration and
continuous deployment for developers
and integration with our
code and container repositories and the
right monitoring
and login tools that our operations engineers are
going to need to
make sure we give the best
availability and the best level of
service to our customers.  users within
cuber net  it is the part of the master is
delegated to the google cloud service
but what control do we have over
the nodes that are going to run our
workloads and how we interact
with them we have two ways of working
with cover nets engine the first is to
interact with the service itself
through the graphical interface or
using the cloud command
so we can define the format and type of
nodes that groups of nodes we want to create
and operations on these clusters
once we have a cluster ready to
work we can interact with it
through the standard command ctl
and  once we are operating with kit ctl
we already benefit from the
self-repair of these nodes by
monitoring signals from each of the
elements where our workloads are running
and replacing it if
we encounter problems the
automatic update of the nodes with the latest
version of  cuber nets engine and cuber
net is auto scaling to resize
the cluster  r automatically according to the
processing needs of
our application or even auto
provisioning nodes to create sets
of nodes that automatically adjust
to the size and format of the
workload we are running all
these options are optional but
some are enabled by default
go  to take a look at how
gobernates engine works in a short demo to
start working with the cuber nets engine
we look for the service in the
start menu this time we are going to use one of
my favorite console tools
our cloud shell
here we have an environment  that allows us to
use a persistent command line
and stores our history
in our control variables
to start deploying an application
in my cluster.
q btl
apply - efe to refer to the file
I want  use in this case
diploid hammel mind
and I will tell you the name space or the partition
in which I want to do this deployment
in this test case
we see that two posts or two
replicas of the workload that
I want to deploy have been created
if now I need to auto scale  the
infrastructure that is supporting
this application I can tell the master
to update the number of replicas in
a different file for that I am going to
use another document in this case
typically key
this document is going to request eight replicas
to be able to receive new load
and we see that automatically q  vernet es
creates these messages to be able to adapt to
the new load needs that my
application is receiving this
interaction can be done through
the command line or through the
graphical interface or the cuber nets api
once I want to expose this service from the
outside so that others can access
it I have to create a service I
can do this with the govern command  tes
expos cube tele expos display mind
referring to the deployment that
I just created in this case the name
of the deployment is engine ex just
in the name space test
and let's see that there is now a
common entry point for all these
workloads that goes  to translate in google
cloud in a balancer with a
public ip ready to take this load
as we have seen that vernet shenjing is
the easiest and most robust way to
start working with containers in the cloud
we can benefit from more than 10
years of experience  from google and from the
latest technology that we are releasing
to always stay at the forefront
of innovation start using the
cover nets engine for free from today
through cloud dot google.com barra
free see you later
ah